[Music]
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I found another free game for you to
grab right now and it does not require
PS plus and it's also available on Xbox
and PC so today I'm console and PC
grenades that title will never catch on
those awesome guys over at Warner
Brothers have given us injustice gods
among us but you need to act quickly as
this will be gone on June 25th that's
less than seven days away so get your
butt in gear and get it downloaded
please do me a favor and throw a like so
this information gets out to more people
here are the details injustice and gods
among us is similar to the Mortal Kombat
series but it's all about the stupid
beings from the DC Universe so if you
want to finally take down the Batman
with Joker or if you want to see if the
flash could beat Superman one on one
here is your chance
the game has brutal super moves which
tie into each character's abilities and
there's a storyline which I liked so
much I made a video about it but nobody
watched it good times bro the game isn't
advertised in the store very well so you
need to search for it injustice gods
among us and there it is hiding in all
the DLC content injustice gods among us
on ps4 at least is the Ultimate Edition
I can't confirm that for other platforms
so if you have an xbox or pc please do
me a favor and write below
the Ultimate Edition includes 6 added
characters 30 more skins and 60 style of
missions to the base game not bad eh as
always and let you know about free games
so slap subscribe to help me help you
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades our
xbox grenade or PC grenade whatever the
hell you like I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]